all right so now that the Last of Us
Series has kicked off on HBO it's only
fitting for us to dive into the rugged
closed off from the world main character
of Joel Miller episode 1 of the series
gives us a brief introduction but we're
gonna be filling in his whole backstory
what his future has in store and why
he's a morally gray character we can't
help but love obviously spoilers for the
game and potential ones for the series
so if you don't want to be infected with
spoilers then sneak off now but if you
enjoyed this video we'd really
appreciate a like and feel free to
subscribe for breakdowns and other
Easter egg videos like this every single
day with that out of the way a huge
thank you for a click
became this I'm your host Jared now
let's get into The Last of Us so episode
1 of the series does a pretty good job
of establishing what we learn about Joel
from the games aside from the brief
timeline change of 10 years Joel was
born and raised in Arlington Texas
growing up alongside his brother Tommy
with the two later moving to Austin
Texas Austin having a large live music
scene Joel found a passion for music
playing the guitar and once even saying
that he aspired to be a singer however
some of his life plans were interrupted
when he married an unnamed woman and
together had their daughter Sarah with
the stress of young Parenthood Joel
unfortunately did not have the
opportunity to attend college and the
same stresses caused him and his wife to
separate surprisingly this no-name woman
is never actually revealed but instead
Joel is taken over as the main caregiver
for Sarah being a single father for most
of his life the two lived an average
Suburban life with Joel working
construction jobs he even had dreams of
starting his own construction business
later on with various build building
plans and books scattered about his
office however he had some difficulties
balancing work and life usually coming
home late and one time was overheard
struggling to keep a Contracting job
despite life's struggles he always found
time for Sarah whether it be a late
night movie watching session or
attending her weekend soccer games the
night of Joel's birthday 32nd in the
game and I believe 36th in the series
Sarah gifted him with a new watch to
replace his old broken one this later
becomes a treasured Memento to Joel
because of what happens on outbreak day
of which starts with their neighbor
Jimmy acting a bit strange and then
escalating to the full-on outbreak we
know during this night though Sarah Joel
and Tommy are trying to escape Austin
only to be caught in a horde of infected
leading to Joel and Sarah escaping but a
major turning point of Joel's life
occurs when a military officer thinks
that they are infected shooting them
resulting in Sarah being mortally
wounded Joel loses the one person he
truly loved and only the watch to
remember her by that's why he fondly
looks at it later even though it's
broken and doesn't work now this is
where the 20-year time Jump happens and
much of Joel's early kind of this life
in between is a mystery though through
brief conversations and other people we
meet along the way there's a general
idea of the character Joel was during
this time shortly after Sarah's death
Joel contemplated ending his own life
after seeing the chaos of what this new
world held but instead chose to survive
fighting alongside his brother Tommy
however in order to survive this took
the two down a dark path of torturing
and deceiving countless innocent people
essentially becoming a hunter these were
like parasitic Bandit type people that
threw any sort of moral code out the
window using any sort of trickery
tactics to Ambush others for their own
personal gain and survival Joel was able
to smuggle the pair into to Boston where
Joel spent most of his days until he was
eventually paired up with Ellie though
after years of seeing nightmares day in
and day out Tommy leaves Joel for the
fireflies very much differing from
Joel's idea of survival The Fallout
between the pair was pretty serious with
I don't ever want to see your Goddamn
face again being the last thing Tommy
said to Joel before heading off to
Wyoming Joel continued his days as a
lone brutal Survivor riding that morally
Gray Line descending more and more into
darkness eventually meeting a woman
named Tess Joel seems to care about her
a fair amount and the pair took on the
role of Smugglers for the Boston
quarantine Zone smuggling brought on the
reputation for Joel as a man to fear
forming relationships with other sketchy
people again only to survive another day
according to Neil druckman the writer of
the two Last of Us games a lot of
inspiration for the Joel character was
borrowed from the Josh Brolin and
character of Mass from the 2007 movie No
Country for Old Men he noted that his
very quiet very cool Under Pressure
traits helped him build the core of Joel
while voice actor Troy Baker built in
more emotional elements to help show
that this character evolves from
heartbroken father to devious Smuggler
into something that is a bit of a
mixture this quiet morally gray Persona
is what makes Joel such an interesting
character throughout this story because
it's never actually said that he was a
hunter rather several context clues hint
at it like he had been on both sides of
things hinting at him having to do what
was needed to be done but a bit ashamed
of his earlier Dark Days him adapting to
this new world shutting off emotions
seemed to be his new way of survival the
second turning point of Joel's life is
when he and Tess are tasked with
smuggling some cargo for Marlene and the
fireflies in exchange for their missing
weapons however it sooner revealed that
this cargo is actually a teenage girl
named Ellie she's a bit of a spicy one
in her attitude though Joel not wanting
to be a babysitter is persuaded by Tess
into taking the job as they hit the road
however there's a huge snag when they
are stopped by military control
revealing that Ellie is actually
infected Joel and Tess are confused why
Marlene would set them up to transport
an infected but Ellie pleads with them
stating that her bite is more than three
weeks old she is immune Joel skeptical
of this Revelation goes along with
transporting her anyway it's the weapons
for him and he is absolutely no
attachment to this degenerate in his
eyes as their Journey continues Joel's
toughened exterior is only so tough
first blaming some of the mishaps on
Ellie's whole involvement like tests
being bitten on their way to meet the
fireflies but Joel never abandons Ellie
sure there is that quiet tough love
nature to him like when Joel is attacked
by a hunter in the hotel Ellie saves his
life with her knife he instantly is
pissed like a father disappointed in
going against his wishes but he soon
learns that Ellie isn't like Sarah she
is maybe a surrogate daughter in the
making but she is stubborn and holds her
own Joel slowly becomes more open with
Ellie alluding to his time as a hunter
talking about Sarah in a loving
memorable way even though it's been
roughly 20 years he still has this
fondness for his lost daughter while
also having reoccurring nightmares of
that night on outbreak day it's really
shown that Joel cares for Ellie like a
daughter when they finally meet up with
Tommy and the others in Wyoming Tommy
gives Joel an old picture of him and
Sarah after a soccer match however Joel
says that he's good showing that those
painful memories of Sarah are something
he wants to put in the rear view mirror
after Bandits attack the damn this is
where Joel's feelings towards Ellie
really shift consoling her asking if
she's okay something not necessarily
shown prior to this it's almost like
that picture of Sarah was his daughter
in a different time a different life and
now Ellie is his shot at a second chance
to have new memories with a daughter he
never got to share with before all of
this Joel was all about handing Ellie
off to a different party as their
responsibility completely forgetting her
but then after this run-in Joel finally
takes on the responsibility to deliver
Ellie to the fireflies it's that
father-daughter relationship that
blossoms and is reflected more so in the
future scenes with Joel trying to
explain like football to Ellie it's Joel
opening up about his hobbies and
passions to someone he cares about once
they arrive at the University in
Colorado only to discover the fireflies
have moved operations to Salt Lake City
there's this small glint of Hope in
Joel's tone that he won't have to end
the journey with Ellie just yet with
them becoming so close he doesn't really
want to pass her along however this is
all cut short as they are tacked by a
group of Bandits resulting in Joel
landing on a rogue piece of rebar
impaling his abdomen this injury almost
ends his life but Ellie is able to nurse
him back to health during the winter
months in a basement of an abandoned
house during this time the roles are
almost reversed where Ellie is the one
looking after Joel and this is the other
side of the coin showing now that the
pair is in for the Long Haul Elias
however captured by members of the same
Bandit group that attacked them at the
University learning that they are
cannibals led by a real creepy man by
the name of David now I won't get too
far into David but he is basically a
demented version of Joel who has
descended much further into the darkness
of this world completely warped so it's
really interesting Dynamic to introduce
him and how Ellie has to maneuver
interactions with this character in
order to locate Ellie Joel reverts to
his old Hunter days eliminating all but
two Bandits and interrogates the pair up
to this point we've seen Joel do some
gnarly things and hinted at a much
darker past but here we see a side of
this loving father that is a straight up
Sinister he's a man that will do
anything to get his daughter back or in
this case Ellie and straight up tortures
the pair it really speaks volumes of
Joel's character how much he has evolved
from even the start of he and Ellie's
journey and there is still that Primal
Rage in him but instantly shifts to
consoling Ellie when he finds her making
mincemeat of David Joel will do anything
for Ellie at this point which makes the
ending such a gut punch of an impact
Joel and Ellie eventually stumbled upon
the fireflies held up in an old hospital
in Salt Lake City advising Joel had made
it there just in time Ellie is being
prepared for surgery and finally a
potential cure can be researched to stop
the infection however when Joel
discovers that Ellie is being sacrificed
for the the procedure is Primal Rage
coupled with the loving father both come
out eliminating most of the fireflies
the doctors and takes Ellie back for
himself it's such a conflicting thing
for Joel to do because a heavy portion
of their Journey he just wants to leave
her on the side of the road and move on
with things but here he theoretically
Dooms Humanity for his own selfish
reasons in a way Joel saving Ellie and
then lying to her in the car ride back
to Wyoming is him wanting to create this
faux life for himself to live in
distracting himself from those
nightmares out there that Tommy had
mentioned earlier Joel is one heck of a
conflicted character at the end of this
he cares deeply for Ellie he wouldn't
let anything happen to her but yet lies
to her face about maybe the biggest
medical advancement in the past few
decades the ending really completes the
complex Journey Joel makes from the
beginning of the story initially Joel is
this loving father who seemingly would
sacrifice himself for his daughter
eventually evolving into someone who is
willing to sacrifice his friends and
finally metaphorically sacrifice all of
humanity for Ellie Troy Baker The Voice
talent for Joel added that in doing this
Joel robbed Ellie of her meaningful
sacrifice to save The Wider World from
the infection and so robbed her life of
a wider meaning because he believed if
we can't save one little world then it's
not a world worth saving Weeks Later
back at the Jackson Community in Wyoming
Joel is a bit conflicted about the
decision he made confiding in Tommy
about what really went down in Salt Lake
City the first thing Tommy asks is if he
told Ellie the truth instead lying that
there was no cure in order to protect
her Joel very much has morphed into a
full-on father figure towards her and
Tommy responds with wouldn't have done
it differently after hearing Joel's
reasoning Joel visits Ellie letting her
know how well she's integrating in with
the community and gives her the guitar
that he found Joel even shares his love
of music with her by playing Future Days
by Pearl Jam softly singing the lyrics
about future days and days of you and me
that resonate with Ellie as she listens
to Joel softly sing this is another key
moment because Joel finally shares his
talents with her again wanting to be
this loving father than giving the
guitar to her for her to learn a couple
years had passed as they fully integrate
into the Jackson Community Joel being
Tommy's brother became a well-known
trusted respected hard-working member in
the community mainly him and Tommy would
Patrol the Mountain View Lodge area
cleaning out infected one winter it was
said that the pair took out over 20
clickers and bloaters in a large horde
up on the mountain Joel continued to
care for Ellie like a daughter teaching
her how to play the guitar finally how
to swim and on her 16th birthday
surprised her by taking her to a nearby
museum Ellie loves museums by the way at
the Museum he surprised Ellie with not
only a model spaceship exhibit but also
a recording of the Apollo 11 launch
having Ellie imagined that she was
flying into space he gifted her a space
pendant to certify her as an official
astronaut roughly a year later Joel had
to finally confront Ellie about the
truth about what really happened all
those years ago at the hospital Ellie
went off to search for her own answers
with Joel reading a note that she had
left and then following her knowing he
couldn't keep this from her Joel admits
the fireflies indeed saw hope in Ellie
and were confident that Akira would be
developed but he intervened stopping
them to save her life this fractured
their relationship as Ellie was no
longer on speaking terms with Joel
sometime later Joel caused quite a stir
at the Jackson annual Winter Dance
trying to stick up for Ellie after
kissing her girlfriend Dina but this was
a bit too overbearing as he wasn't her
actual father and this caused
embarrassment later that night Ellie
confronted Joel playing his guitar on
his porch she scolded him for stealing
her true purpose in life with Joel
responding that if God had given him a
second chance he would have done the
same thing over again this affirmed his
love and care and selfishness towards
Ellie but also allowed them to slowly
rebuild their relationship on March 2nd
2038 Joel and Tommy got caught up in a
blizzard on a patrol saving a stranded
hiker named Abby Anderson as they escape
the weather and infected to a hideout at
the Baldwin Mansion where Abby's friends
were staying this was all a trap though
because once the two introduced
themselves the room fell silent and Abby
shot Joel in the leg they knocked out
Tommy and tied up Joel wrapping his leg
in a make shift tourniquet so he
wouldn't bleed out Joel urges them to do
whatever speech they have planned and
get it over with it's not revealed at
the time though but Abby is the daughter
of the doctor that Joel shot at the
hospital all those years ago to save
Ellie Abby finally caught up to him to
get her revenge beating him with a
nearby Golf Club Ellie tries to save him
but Abby's group overpowers her holding
her down to watch Joel's Last Breath
pleading and threatening them Abby
Smashes in Joel's head ending his life
Ellie in a panic promises she's gonna
get her revenge but is knocked
unconscious Joel was 56 when he died and
was the closest thing to a father that
Ellie had it's an interesting parallel
of how Joel's Journey started with him
watching his daughter pass and then at
the end his new daughter Ellie watches
as he passes away Joel's body was later
buried in the Jackson Cemetery with
several member members of the community
leaving condolences outside of his house
Ellie never fully recovered from the
tragedy of watching Joel that day she
later had several moments of PTSD
reminding her of that nightmarish day
which affected her and drove her to get
even just like what Abby had set out to
do in the end one of the most
heartbreaking moments from the game is
Ellie trying to play Joel's guitar she
tries to play the same song Joel was
playing the night that she confronted
him about everything but after losing a
couple of fingers it's impossible for
her to strum the same tune without
messing up this small thing that
connected the two was also taken from
her as Ellie breaks down once again
leaving the guitar behind
honestly The Last of Us and last of us
too are the best video game stories I've
ever played I even got a bit emotional
during a couple moments from the second
game and that last guitar scene was
definitely one of them druckman and crew
did a great job of fleshing out these
characters especially Joel a man with a
clouded past some might even say a
villain in a certain point of view but
that doesn't stop him from being one of
the most complex well-developed video
game characters out there again part of
me would have absolutely done what he
did for Ellie obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on Joel did he do the
right things and what do you think of
Pedro Pascal's portrayal of the
character so far and I'll let you know
we're currently running the competition
giving away three copies of Black Adam
and Dawn of the Dead on the 15th of
January and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop your comments Down Below on the
last of us we pick the comments at
random at the end of every single month
and the winners of last month are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out our Last of Us episode
1 breakdown Paul gets into everything it
is fantastic go check it out but with
that out of the way thank you as always
for watching I've been Jared I'll see in
the next one take care and peace